what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the sit down where I bring on prominent
guests and I interview them one-on-one
today I have a special guest Mike
Buchanan you are the author of two books
feminism the ugly truth you can hold it
up okay show the people show the people
lord of the frauds right no the fraud of
the Rings
oh [__] my bad
okay okay the
feminism the ugly truth and the fraud of
the Rings show them the book
um you're also in men's rights activist
and a politician well uh uh
um I want to be politician I guess yes I
I launched Justice for men and boys as a
political party in 2013. okay
um and but we we deregistered um just
just just a few months ago but we still
campaign against feminism and feminists
who as we all know are evil to the core
and I guess we'll come on to that really
they always seem like polite women
they're just so so nice now this is a
this is a looker
oh wow
um but but we we it wasn't getting
traction as a political party so we
deregistered a few months ago but but we
still campaigned for men's and boys
human rights and and against feminism so
what made you want to start that
um I worked for the conservative party
for a couple of years 2006 to eight
um during which time I I basically
delivered something that was to put 11.5
million pounds into their party coffers
over the next few years and I really
should now be Baron Buchanan of Bedford
so I mean 11.5 million pounds do you
think that would buy a baron let's see
wouldn't you but there we go
um
um but in 2009 David Cameron who was a
although conservative party leader was
very Progressive as was recently Boris
Johnson
um he announced his intention to
introduce all women shortlists for
prospective uh MPS
which is a deeply you know it's the most
unconservative thing that you could you
could imagine
um and so a woman's short list all women
shortlist yeah okay so basically when
when somebody is being selected to
become a prospective mp uh there's a
short list what does NP stand for oh
Member of Parliament yeah sorry I forget
it's not just a British audience sorry
okay yeah that's kind of like Congress
I'm guessing yeah I never remember if
it's Congress or the Senate but yeah
um but yeah so it's the House of Commons
you know the 650 MPS and so he basically
said he was going to introduce short
lists with only women on them so as to
increase the proportion of female MPS in
the conservative party
because the the the labor party had had
them for years and uh yeah
so so
um that's what kind of woke me up to I
think for the to take the red pill you
know to use that analogy that there's
something deeply deeply troubling going
on here and it's how I got interested in
feminism and gender politics
um and I retired around I think uh about
13 years ago
to devote the rest of my life to
challenging feminism and fighting for
men's rights and I've never regretted
that for a moment
so you talk about marriage and divorce
yes what what's wrong with marriage
today it seems like a great a great deal
no I think all women should marry and no
men
it is it is uh you know you'll forgive
me for sort of restricting this to the
UK but okay but I suspected all this is
true from what I hear from them you know
in North America as well
um it is no marriage is no longer a
contract
um but men men lose so many rights once
they marry so
um the some some legislation which which
came into effect last year enabled no
fault divorce
so a partner can file for divorce and
they're sorry a person a husband or a
wife can file for divorce
and their partner didn't know about it
until six weeks
before before the before the divorce is
made final so if I file
how long would he not know
well it could be anything but probably
not long but I mean months probably wow
so you could file and he doesn't even
have to know no no until six weeks
beforehand okay and and it's called it's
called no fault divorce so literally for
any reason you know that he's starting
to annoy you a bit oh it's getting
boring because it keeps talking yeah
come on say we should get divorced over
chores yeah yeah yeah so it's it's it's
it's truly appalling so men men have no
rights and particularly they they have
no automatic rights of access to their
children and we can talk about the
family courts which which are um which
are you know truly diabolical uh but
people often say that the family courts
are broken but it's it's nonsense
they're they're they're the family
courts are doing what they're designed
to do which is basically to
keep men away from their children so as
to fleece them financially
and the judges and the magistrates and
the lawyers they're all Crooks basically
because there's you know you know men
will pay huge amounts of money to try
and see their children I I
um I know one man that spent 150 000
pounds
trying trying well in fact his son is
his son who's denied access to his
children
um and he so he spent on his behalf 150
000 pounds still still no access because
if if a woman wants to deny
um deny her ex-husband or ex-partner
access to the children
um it'll happen and the court the courts
will enable her to do that so what do
you mean they're designed to do that
because
um a lot of times the pushback I get is
there's no specific law that says men
cannot have access to their children
well there's no specific law but but
there doesn't need to be this is this is
a problem with so many men's issues
um
there's no I mean shockingly there's no
automatic rights for a biological parent
to have access to their children it's
not it's not an automatic assumption
um they have to fight for it um and if
you're a working-class man you know you
will not have the money to do it so so
lawyers will typically tell working
class men
just give up you know and it's of course
it's
you know so so so it drives I mean the
male suicide rate overall is three and a
half times out of the female suicide
rate but it triples again following
exposure in the family courts and now I
my my my my suicide rate triple triples
wow
Family Court okay
um mainly through denial of access to
Children
um now I have two two wonderful
daughters and uh the the family broke up
when they're eight or nine
um and had had I been denied access to
them I wouldn't be here today Paul I
think it's astonishing that anybody can
survive it you know I could be a bit
careful here because you know I don't
want to sort of get people think about
suicide but what is the cruelest thing
you can do to a human being it's got to
be denying them access to their children
um but that's where all the money comes
from I mean lawyers and it's it's one of
the reasons I mean the entire system is
is designed to to fleece men so for
example ten ten years ago
um the the law was changed so that so
that there was no automatic right to
Legal Aid in a divorce case
um
so
um but there were a number of grounds on
which that on which men or women could
could get it
and one
um one of the grounds was
um domestic abuse
so the stats for domestic claiming
domestic abuse just went through the
roof and now in more than 50 of cases
um really it's more than 50. it's more
than 50 of cases
um
domestic abuse is alleged because that
is the way
to to ensure that you know if you don't
want your ex-husband to see the kids
that will absolutely guarantee it wow
um and of course these are civil courts
you know they're not Criminal Courts so
it's almost it's very rare anyway for
there to be any finding of facts or any
investigation so a woman through her I
mean lawyers will recommend this to them
as you can imagine
so you know you know lawyers will say
well if you if you claim you are
domestically abused or coerced or what
what does what does that mean
um then you know you you could have been
the best husband in the world but you
get that false allegation there it won't
be investigated you won't be able to see
your kids
and that's it it's it's it is beyond
cruel Beyond cruel
and you said they get free lawyers if
they do that well this is another
interesting thing they
um
they they they they get legal aid it's
not even means tested not in almost all
areas of the law legal aid is means
tested
but but for this you know you could be
the richest woman on the planet
and you will get legal aid oh still yeah
certain cases of abuse or alleged abuse
yeah so and but the important thing is
that the the the the the the numbers the
allegations of the frequency of so the
allegations of domestic abuse are so
much higher than we know them to be
right so basically it's a scam and
everybody knows it's a scam what's that
what are they like out of a hundred men
how many are abusive would you say
yeah I'm not sure I know it's quite come
up with it with that figure
um but
um I always whenever people ask about
domestic abuse I always Point them to
the world's
um
the world's largest ever study of the
literature on domestic or interpersonal
violence
and that's the partner abuse state of
knowledge project pasc 13.
and they they they they they reviewed
thousands of studies
um and uh they they they found that in
about 60 of straight couples will come
on to lesbian couples in a minute
hopefully but in 60 about 60 of
straight couples where there's domestic
violence
um the the violence is by bi-directional
so sometimes the woman will be the first
to strike the man sometimes the man will
be the first to strike the woman that
leaves the whole issue of provocation
exactly okay yeah so so I mean that that
leaves aside the whole issue of
provocation which we can maybe talk
about later
um but the interesting thing is in the
40 of cases where the violence is always
one way I mean literally always
the perpetrator is twice as likely to be
the woman as the man yeah and this is
this is so this is this has been
as I say this is the biggest ever study
and can I just recommend
um a book to to your to your supporters
um William Collins
um runs a website called The Illustrated
empathy Gap and he wrote this book The
empathy Gap male disadvantages and the
mechanisms of their neglect in 2019
and it blows apart feminist myth after
lie after you know it just destroys them
um so 700 Pages
um it's not cheap because it's such a
big book it's probably got a thousand
but the e-book is extraordinary sells
for under five pounds it's got like a
thousand hyperlinks you know so anybody
who wants data that will destroy
feminist myths and lies that's that's
the book to go for
so
you you talked about children's access
to parents following family breakdowns
and fatherlessness yeah
well it's just
it you know
it is child abuse right it's nothing
less than child abuse to women that do
that should face jail time now one time
going back 20 or 30 years women who
denied contact repeatedly could could
expect a short-term in jail
these days courts will very seldom even
I mean if a woman frustrates contact she
she'll she'll get away with it every
time I've spoken to man that
um
she's still got full custody yeah even
though she was proven to have been not
letting him see the kids yeah I think
it's actually insane I couldn't believe
it yeah and there's this feminist
narrative a lying feminist narrative but
then again that's implied in the word
feminist isn't it
um that men are more likely to harm
children and again you know you look at
Collins's book is probably the best best
place to go
um more children are killed and abused
by I mean far more children are abused
and killed by their mothers than by
their fathers wow
and yet there's this thing that's you
know men are a danger to children the
the um in terms of you know all forms of
abuse combined
um
mothers are I think seven or eight times
more likely to abuse their kids than
than fathers wow
so there's financial support now for for
single mothers basically from the States
you mean yeah yeah
and also also of course from from you
know I mean the most of these men who
can't get to see their children still
have to pay
um so so I I either the ex-partner will
will have to pay despite not seeing his
kids very likely or the state will pay
and of course I think that that
you know the that's why so many women
will not
you know don't have partners because
they you know the state is you know it's
not difficult to get on with funding are
bad decisions exactly so here's a reward
for I was thinking about this I'm like
if you make a man really angry and you
give at another man and you give him a
gun and say you can legally kill that
other dude yeah I so many guys would do
it yeah but they're angriest and that's
what they do to women basically in
marriage that they're at our like when
are we the worst version of ourselves I
I think do we ever wish our exes well no
we never we never do and then the
government gives us like basically a gun
to make their lives hell I agree I mean
every female trait which you can regard
as a bit negative or very negative it's
just absolutely massively you know
encouraged and I I'd touch on there you
know talking about murder
I think I'd include in there and again
this is something that you can
absolutely put put at the door of
feminist abortion
70 the World Health Organization
estimates
um their last estimate I think last year
was was of 75 million wow abortions a
year this is a and I I don't I don't shy
from using the word holocaust this is a
never-ending Holocaust we hear 70
something years on from World War II
about six million Jews and so we should
but this is this is 12 times that number
every year against the most defenseless
it's
I I honestly don't think that any
society that
that finances the killing of unborn
children can call itself a civilized
society right I agree and it's as much
it is as you know it's as much um as far
as I can say the men's issue as as a
woman's issue yeah I mean guys have no
say and if you abort their child a lot
of men don't even know the girl's
pregnant no well there's no legal
obligation
that most abortions are men in
relationships like I I would guess the
relationships more than one night stands
yes
um I think I think if a woman's in a
long-term relationship with a guy and
they're not getting married it's more on
her than him she's just kind of like
waiting for the next thing yeah the
woman said to me just just the other day
that um it wasn't surprising that we
used to have a big problem in the UK
with teenage pregnancies and that is
absolutely for you know they've
plummeted um in in recent years
um but one of the eight I mean women
over 35
those they're I mean the the abortion
rate has never been higher in the UK 57
years after the ACT
um but um it's free up to six months
which is crazy 24 weeks it's at which
point the fetus would probably be viable
yeah so you could you could have in a
hospital two operating theaters side by
side one of which is killing and
dismembering a 24 year old feeders into
the next one they're trying to save it
yeah how that is just morally and
defensible as far as I'm concerned well
and even I've heard that like Plan B is
in like a um
the other birth control can cause
abortions but they don't really cite
that I don't know if that's true I just
had another guest tell me that the other
day right but I think you know also
sorry this woman the other day she said
to me that she she thinks this
phenomenon of 30 plus women having so
many abortions is down to them
um getting deliberately pregnant to try
and get a man to commit and then when he
won't then then you know then then the
abortion all right doubt it I mean like
nowadays it's like
like oops anymore it's like situated
situation chips like I was like
seriously we make the worst decisions
the more mate selection we have because
a hundred years ago it was all on like
the fathers the fathers would pick but
I'm like the war choice we have
we can't be making that good of choices
if we're aborting like one out of three
of us is getting an abortion I know I
know it's crazy and I mean for 50 plus
years women have had pretty
pretty
um infallible contraception yeah
and you know men used to know this they
used to know where you're kind of
supposed to protect the women from
ourselves you know like what was Adam's
biggest mistake listening to Eve
really and like you know because our
nature is just kind of chaotic yeah well
I mean Jordan Peterson talks about this
doesn't he that's a you know about the
yin and yang sort of chaos women of
chaos yeah and and men are order there's
never been a successful female-led
civilization and there never will be one
I mean women women are
disasters in in professions you you take
in the UK in particular
um women have been favored for medical
school places since the 1970s 50 years
the NHS I get how Americans think the
NHS would be would be great but it is a
complete disaster
some some do not the conservative okay
but the whole the whole free at the
point of use thing you know is you know
um but it's an absolute disaster because
you know women
um
you know you know from the moment they
leave edu full-time education women are
less likely to work at all than men
um less likely to work full-time so
there's basically a collapse in capacity
um which is why I mean as a young man I
I could see my doctor the same day now
it could be three weeks
um it's actually disastrous and so so
the the drop-in capacity has been in
large part sorted out by bringing in
doctors from the third world these are
poor countries Pakistan India and so on
they spend all this money and then these
people come over it's it's it's it's
appalling I mean if we stop training
female doctors for a generation or two
the NHS would pick up no end but it's
true of all sorry the ball professions
really I was thinking about this I'm
like really if women were banned from
the workforce I think there would be an
increase in efficiency not a decrease I
was thinking about that I know I think
you're right HR would be gone and I'm
like oh Cuban remains because I really
started thinking because I I had a tweet
the other day through the show on
tonight and I was like outside of
reproduction to not take the kids out of
it they're like women give life yes we
know what like could Society function
without women and I'm thinking for all
of history it did yeah it's interesting
there's exceptions right there's always
been like high IQ Cleopatra yeah but is
that the rule right and I was thinking
like
I was like all the industry so then
people were tweeting at me all these
industries that women run and I just
would look at them and think well these
are all the industries We complain about
the DMV in the US Health Care education
yes these are all
your doctor lies to you the teachers
indoctrinate you yeah and the DMV is so
slow that in that um Disney movie they
made a sloth yes and that's like a 90
I'm like maybe I guess we're okay
secretaries we could be secretaries
right but I'm like all these jobs
they're not really like needed no well
education I mean State education at
least the dumbing down of Education yeah
I mean 11 year olds were
that is certainly in mathematics which I
guess is like an acid test of all this
in mathematics 11 year olds were were
better educated 40 years ago than 16
year olds today
really by a country mile and but at what
age so 11 and 16. so there was a thing
called 11 plus until about 40 years ago
and so so somebody uh history there's a
guy
who runs a channel called I think it's
history debunked and he had maths
questions from an 11 plus from I think
about 40 years ago and a modern GCSE so
this is for 16 year olds
and it wasn't that they were comparable
the one for 11 year olds was just quite
stratospherically more difficult than
what 16 year olds and also I mean 40
years ago most teachers were were were
men
and really yeah but but now it's mostly
women and it now takes because why do
you think that is
oh I think just through discrimination
that the uh recruitment time
um
but yeah I mean a bit like medical
schools you know advice you know you
know would take on more women than menza
um
but I mean for years and years now
um it's you know most classes in the
secondary system will have a teacher
usually a woman and a teaching assistant
or virtually Always a Woman
so basically two women
are teaching kids less well than one man
did
40 years ago and also I mean I also run
a thing called campaign
oh that's so funny but I also run a
thing called campaign for merit in
business like yeah I seem to be the only
MRA men's rights advocate in the world
that's really agitated about the issue
of women on boards
Awards on corporate boards on major
corporate boards things like the ftse
hundred and the ftse 250 and Fortune
500. like we can make decisions it's
like get us out of there well well the
thing is that
um 11 years ago in 2012 I gave evidence
to a House of Commons committee inquiry
um because even by then there were quite
a number of longitudinal studies
showing a causal link and it only
longitudinal studies can show a causal
link
um between increasing gender diversity
on boards and corporate Financial
decline
it was just black and white so there's
no Grays it was just and all these all
these all these studies said yes there's
there's a causal link you you put more
women to your boards you're likely to
get you know profitability Decline and
I've I've been I'm almost like a one-man
campaign on that one but but this
Insanity the idea that men oppress women
get out of here they they will it's it's
it's men who've been who are driving
this mobile number boards nonsense well
and I realized I'm like they just like
put us in these positions we suck and
they just don't tell us that we suck
well one of the amazing things Pearl is
that over 95 of these female directors
are non-executive directors
so non-executive so these are not great
business people
the
um and of course they what does that
mean it's like a they kind of review
things it's like a lot of money for no
work or very little work
um but even just like there because
they're a woman basically yeah
um not not contributing things and and I
think one of the reasons that they're so
toxic at the top of companies is that
women are risk averse yeah so so they
will always advise not to take risks but
so it's kind of like having a football
team with 11 goalkeepers and we Trend
towards like equality and egalitarianism
you know that's why I don't even think
women should vote that's that's I I know
your position on that I think that's
fascinating because
um we'll always pick security over
Freedom yeah always yeah so it's like uh
you know I I I would you know
I think most men if you put them in a
room and nobody could see what they
answered and you said look guys
ban women from working ban women from
voting you get to vote on this I think
more than 50 of men
would secretly say yes yeah and of
course the extraordinary thing is that
women now have all the rights that
feminists asked you know were demanding
I mean all of them a lot of them are
actually privileges not rights but but
they have them all and they've never
been more miserable women you know so
like the more privileges they get the
less happy they are which is you know I
mean they were happier when most women
were stay-at-home mums and so on but I'm
slightly happier than you know
then then then so many women today yeah
so so I mean feminism was never about
the quality of women's happiness it was
always about
um well you actually I remember once you
had a it was either a banner or a
placard
um when you were talking I think in
Piccadilly Circus or somewhere and it
was feminism is the pursuit of of Female
Supremacy yeah and I don't know if you
know but there's a video
um going back before 2015. there was a
um he's still alive a British video
blogger called man woman myth
and he he one of his most famous uh we
have 130 of his videos on our channel on
our YouTube channel and one of his one
of his videos was titled exactly the
same feminism is the pursuit of Female
Supremacy
and so it's not about happiness it's not
about it's about
getting more power to women destroying
the family number one because that is
that's always been the number one
feminist objective well when I realized
that there wasn't any waves of feminism
that was kind of because I always
thought there was like first wave was
good right but then you realize they
were planning assassinations yes at the
time the suffragettes yes yeah yeah and
I'm like well does that sound like a
good movement well no it's funny people
sometimes say oh it's been corrupted all
right it's been no it's been feminism
has has been a pile of BS right from the
beginning yeah um you certainly go back
to the Seneca Falls Convention in New
York state about 1850 I think give or
take a year or two but that was you know
they were very clear but women were
privileged then I mean I know you really
know this stuff
um that if a woman incurred a debt back
back in that time yeah and she couldn't
pay it and the man couldn't he went to
prison that's patriarchy that patriarchy
we don't need that kind of patriarchy
and in New York you could sue you could
send your husband to jail if he wasn't
paying the bills right
and they're like why he doesn't we have
to go 50 50. not then you could sue I
was like what and you pointed out in
your reaction video to that amazing
Piers Morgan uh interview that women
could sell property without telling
sorry wives could sell property without
telling husbands husbands it would be a
crime for a husband to do that the idea
that women whatever
oppressed I mean Men actually can't
defend themselves I mean the idea that
men could oppress women that men men
cannot
defend themselves against women I mean
until maybe 100 or so years ago
that that I guess was largely restricted
to the private sphere but now women have
learned how to manipulate men and abused
men
um in the public sphere they're they're
they're doing it and men men will not
fight them
it will not do it well I realized I'm
like it's females Natures we always want
to control men yeah and that's like bad
for society do you know anything I think
I've always women always have control
men no you know yeah they always have
yeah well then I found out that the
first female property owner in the U.S
was in the 1600s that's brilliant yes it
was like what we could known properly
you know there's women that have yeah I
I I recently um
I I there's there's I'm sure you'll have
heard of Julie Bendel probably the most
uh Infamous radical feminist journalist
in the UK oh okay I've heard a very
Wallen oh no no no no so this is a this
is the current day oh so Julie bindle is
probably the number one
um radical feminist journalist okay
um in in the UK you really should get
her on you should interview her okay
um and I'll happily join you that would
be fun I've been trying I don't know if
she if she's a feminist they don't like
to talk I don't think she will but but
you could always annoy her by asking
that'd be something but um
but
um yeah so so so she has a sub stack um
account and it costs five pounds a month
but but so so I joined that
and the reason I do is is is is is is
the feminists will come out with all
sorts of claims there's one the other
day she just spouted nonsense after
nonsense so I could just point to a link
say no check out this link you know this
rub issue so there was this old feminist
well they still and this woman came out
with it it was brilliant
um she said that the number one cause of
death of of of of women I forget the
ages
um is domestic violence
you know I mean we start with obesity
like come on what I'll start with like
heart disease or something yeah so it's
just so insane you know but but she's
just been told all this stuff and she
just absolutely believed it all and she
was very clearly she accused me of
gaslighting and I said so I'm presenting
you with facts yeah and that's
gaslighting what does that tell you
because you know what I realized all the
feminists just make up words so we don't
know what they're talking about and they
can say anything means anything right
that's what I realized because like
that's they do in the courts with like
abuse yes they're like oh it's like
coercion coercive control like
gaslighting and I'm just like all these
they're just adding these big war I
people that use two bigger words I don't
trust because I'm like why are you using
these words for no reason and men will
not challenge them yeah they'll um
Paul Elam who's probably the most
prominent
men's rights activist in the world I'd
say has been for a good many years um
did I think it did a whole video titled
something like
um a measure of a man's character is his
ability to say no to women
and I think he absolutely distilled it
all down into that because
you know I I I've known you know I've
known men sort of abused by by partners
and it's it's a very sad thing you know
they they they will not I mean you know
the males are taught from the earlier
stage you don't hit girls you don't hit
women and of course for women that's
that's just uh a green light to just
it's just the question is are we equal
or are we not equal right if we're equal
then expect equal treatment they can hit
back yeah if you're not equal to maybe
like that would make more sense to have
special privileges yeah right yeah like
like done then you're not equal right
but you're saying you're equal so be
equal yeah I mean to go back to your
point about about the vote yeah that's a
very interesting one um
I I'd personally have women keep the
vote
as long as men had equal rights with
women now feminists always say they want
equal rights
and you also a specific you know if you
say feminist name me one area where you
don't have a nickel right with men that
they've got nothing and I save them I
can give you 20 areas where you have
rights that I don't we'll name them
you've got the list I think oh here so
it's like I'll read them back okay okay
oh is this one so so the these uh
divorce so these are issues covered in
they're on our website j4mb.org.uk
um
basically this is a list of areas where
the human rights of men and boys are
assaulted by the state's actions and
inactions almost always to privileged
women and girls
wow okay I didn't I didn't realize I
thought this was I didn't realize that
that's what this was so Reproductive
Rights you're saying including abortion
yeah but not not just abortion but yeah
for Woody alcohol Spectrum Disorder I've
never heard of okay fetal alcohol
Spectrum Disorder yeah so obviously as
the name suggests where
fetuses are damaged by the woman
drinking alcohol
um it is the number one cause of
avoidable
mental health incapacitation across the
developed World wow huge huge numbers of
huge numbers and and
um so basically it's committing gross
sorry Grievous bodily harm against your
baby
women in the UK and I suspect the same
is true in well in most most developed
countries face no sanctions they can
hand over this horribly
um you know the the this this baby which
has got huge brain damage probably
physical damage as well just walk away
and it's just women are not held
accountable right you know just in in so
many areas genital mutilation that's the
circumcision circumcision
um
both female and male genital mutilation
um are are implicitly illegal in the UK
since the offenses against the Persian
act 1861 because it's basically
inflicting Grievous well certainly
um probably Grievous bodily harm
without the informed consent of course
you know I mean Jews will circumcise
their sons at eight days Muslims at
different times
um so there's absolutely no question
that it's a crime in the UK but of
course the No No prosecutions abroad I I
try to bring a private prosecution of
of a circumcising doctor and it was it
was refused
um but but
um feminists in the 1980s in the UK had
anti-fgm legislation brought in so the
40 years ago
um but male genital mutilation carries
on it's also I should say people often
say oh well it's much less harmful
and it's that's that's an absolute myth
because feminists when they talk about
FGM we'll talk about the absolute most
extreme you know very rare forms of FGM
um and of course they they don't care
about the impact of MGM but but 90 and
more than 90 of the nerve cells
in the penis that's I never I didn't
think I'd use that word in an interview
with you but there we go
um more than 90 of the nerve cells in in
the penis that give men pleasure during
sex they're called meister's corpuscles
are in the foreskin
so the entire point of MGM is is to
damage men physically and there's
there's a rabbi Moses maimonides in the
13th century who said that was the
entire point so that's so that uh Jewish
men couldn't have so much sex they'd be
more likely to wait really to remain
faithful to their wife that was the
point of it yeah yeah when it goes back
to Egyptian time so we're not quite sure
what the original purpose was but no
it's it's um it's it's it's a very it's
always very damaging you guys would have
like better sex basically if they
weren't circumcised apparently
um
um you know and men have committed
suicide over all sorts of things man
I've committed suicide over
circumstances oh yeah through being
circumcised once if they if it goes
no well it always goes wrong this is the
thing people often talk about botched
things but even if it goes right you
still lose 90 of the feeling and it's
one of the reasons that um the the the
the
Lubes sell so much more in in America
than let's say the UK because it
actually has like the foreskin has like
20 functions
um that and there are some amazing what
we call intactivists campaigning on this
and probably the number one is an
american guy in California brother k
uh brother K and the bloodstained men
and they they they campaign
they basically have white boiler suits
with a sort of red patch around down
here incredible man
um
but it's just and there's a guy called
Brendan Brandon Morata who directed a
film called American circumcision I'm
sure you can get it on Netflix or Amazon
and so on and I I strongly recommend
that
I've never
I've known people campaigned for
so really see they lose 90 percent of
like nerves of the nerve cells that give
pleasure yeah wow
wow and it all goes back to certainly in
in America it's um the one of the great
proponents of it was Kellogg's was Dr
Kellogg of cornflakes Fame
um and he he recommended it so as to
stop boys masturbating
um or at least sort of minimize how
often the you know
um
because and it's really just a stifle
male sexuality yeah because male
sexuality is shamed yeah that's why we
call it men right right eggs yeah yeah
and and it's um I heard that women used
to be known as the more sexual ones yeah
I don't know I mean just take on Kellogg
for a second yeah sorry that's okay
um so
so I mean circumcision if we can call it
that has always been as described as a
solution in search of a problem
um so back in the Victorian era it was
thought that um you know men would end
up mad from excessive masturbation all
this kind of thing
um and today one of the reasons I think
more the
World Health Organization I think it is
is it and the Bill Gates Bill and
Melinda Gates organization
are funding the circumcision of 20 plus
million
um sub-Saharan males in a in a bid to
reduce the spread of AIDS but the
evidence behind it is close to
non-existent
um it's it's it's truly appalling but
Kellogg also recommended the application
of carbolic acid to the clitorises of
baby girls again to desensitize them
so
I've never heard of that so Bill Gates
is basically funding
well the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation which I think is very much
run by her and the feminist
um and I mean I've never known a
feminist
um well I mean Julie Bendel
sort of makes light of it you know they
couldn't care about because you know
this is something that damages men so
why would they care you know right
what about it says um children's brain
damage from contact Sports okay I played
basketball does that mean I'm damaged it
depends if you headed it um but in the
UK at least
um
only boys play compulsory sports that in
that involve
um well I mean basically this is
basically it's soccer and rugby
um
I don't think too many boys sort of uh a
box at least not not fish not at schools
um but but there's a direct link between
uh concussion and brain damage of course
um which is probably going to end
American football one day I I God I
adore American football but it is it is
absolutely brutal and the the impact on
brains of that kind of concussion is is
just appalling we we have rugby players
who played in international competitions
five or ten years ago that don't
remember being in them
um wow because because of concussion you
know just join the game it's it's tragic
and a lot lots of them get Alzheimer's
um you know much younger than the
general population so so but basically
so it's only boys
because you know and it goes back to the
empathy Gap it's only boys that that we
that we can basically harm their brains
we wouldn't dream of putting making
girls through that we wouldn't never do
it
and then you have education that goes
back to teachers or would you say men
are discriminated in education oh
absolutely yes
um again Collins you know he he comes
this supremely well in 1997
in the 1987-88 Academic Year
um
we had the replacement
um of what were called o levels with
gcses and GCSE has been with us ever
since there's a myth that well levels
were very much about
um exams okay so your entire grading was
down to how well you performed an exam
and there was a feminist myth that boys
did much better there are all sorts of
theories about why but but but the
statement was that boys did much better
in a Grade wise than girls
it was a complete myth I mean they were
just so close together it was almost
uncanny
um but in in so in 1987 eight they
introduced uh gcses
and for the first time that included a
lot of teacher
teacher assessments you know ongoing
them and the reason for the reason they
introduced that was that that introduced
a pro-girl bias into the grading
and if you look at the grades Yeah so
basically they
um both male and female teachers will
will give a higher grade to a girl than
to a boy if you know because they they
again it may be hard wiring I I don't
know
um why you don't know okay again it may
be a hard one but it's a
well-established well-established fact
so uh Collins has a terrific graph where
he shows the attainment of boys and
girls you know a bit you know from like
the 1950s to the present day and the
gender education Gap happened that year
so all of a sudden girls spiked in you
know compared to boys and that Gap has
been with us ever since
and the the the the worst performing
cohorts of school children is white
working-class boys
and that's been that's been true for for
a great many years but the Department of
Education doesn't doesn't concern
doesn't consider that an issue
you know it never is an issue when men
are do men or boys are doing badly it's
never who like who cares right
um but uh yeah
so this was so is it like a sorry could
you explain the part again where you're
talking about what was introduced in the
schools like what it was okay so that
was a continuous assessment okay so so
that meant that uh teachers could give
grades
um you know based on class work and so
on
so they they would they would whether
consciously or not would would give
higher marks what was it before it was
it was exactly sit down exams yeah and
that and that that of course oh so
before it was like you you had maybe
three months and then you or one month
whatever it was and it was just tests
well you you basically it was um
basically tested let's say at 16 and 18.
but this is 16 year olds that we're
talking about now
um so yes you know you would have
sit-down tests of exams of maybe two or
two hours or something and uh and your
maths ranking was based on that
so you can do like homework assignments
exactly the whole shooting match and so
so so then basically what that did was
to replace objectivity with subjectivity
um which is true
87 88 and it's it's true wherever you
find females outperforming males you'll
find there's been something compromised
um the the you know um on a Level
Playing Field men will always beat women
uh particularly at the higher levels so
the example I love to talk about is
women's chess
I mean how heavy are those pieces that
women can't quite manage you know they I
mean really women's chess there's only
ever been one woman in the top ten uh
Grand Masters and why is that you know
well yeah no I was trying to think of
something that like women did better
than men
I couldn't think of anything because
even men are better parents if you look
at the numbers I once had the great
answer to that question and this moment
please I've been trying to think of it
she looked very strained at the question
because I said tell me one area where
women do but and she said dressage
dressage now what's that well it's it's
an Olympic sport and it was described by
um I can't remember who it was by an
American politician as ballet for horses
um so it's basically where horses do
funny okay you know and and the previous
Olympics a woman had won that
and I said yeah but I I've always
thought in dressage it's the horse that
should get the award should get the
medal rather and this turned out to be a
gelding so I said the only reason that
this woman got this woman got got the
medal was because of a man a male
carried her all the way
I'm like I bet you if that they said it
you get up two million dollars for
winning this men would figure out how to
do it yeah they really would I'm like
men just one of the things I'm amazed at
is that there's imagine your number what
sorry 100
um male tennis player in the world for
God's sake identify as transgender and
and you know and then you know you could
you'll slay Serena Williams you know
sixth love sorry six nil six nine you
won't even have to pay pay five sets I
will tell you what I do think women are
better at oh go on manipulation oh yes
yes there isn't nobody it's a total
super shape-shift and manipulate better
than women but look we had to do that to
get resources historically it is don't
hate the player hate the game it's a
superpower it is the the one and only
but going back to um have you seen those
interviews of those women that woman
that like literally hired a hit man on
her husband yes yes and then he comes in
and she's like oh no baby I did it and
like the man was almost convinced even
though he'd just seen video of her doing
it yeah that's how good
we had someone Ramon Sozo I think his
name was at one of our International
conferences on men's issues in London
and his women sorry his his um his women
his wife had had taken out a contract
and had him killed
um but uh had somehow managed to
so I mean anyway it turned out to be
like a policeman
shouldn't really be asking policemen I'm
not anyway so they they can't even kill
right so you can't even hire a hitman
right but I think I think a lot of
murders of men are proxy killings but
um so in this case they they obviously
wired up this guy in the car and that
camera and so on and they showed him
they they took this guy down the beach
and had a makeup artist put like a you
know what looked like a bullet hole
there and blood and so that so they
showed showed her this um this this
Photograph she smiled and she said good
job good job
and she so she was obviously convicted
um but um going back to women
um
the the the I I don't know if we've
covered this already but
at the time of the um
1967 abortion act which was
overwhelmingly brought in by Men by the
way male politicians to their Eternal
shame
um
1967. I mean like 90 of them get women
to vote for him it's it's scandalous
it's scandalous it wasn't in any party's
Manifesto but that's that's another
thing yeah but but the average number of
children that a woman would have in 1967
was around two and a half
that's like 1.2 right well it's about
one and a half I think so it's like
there's one thing one thing women have
to get right have enough kids and they
can't even manage that
I know that's what I'm like men are
meant to protect us from ourselves no
because that's what I couldn't figure
out why they couldn't change some of
these laws that's what kind of brought
me to the women shouldn't vote and it's
because all the politicians are
pandering to the women to get elected
they they pay only to but there is no
men's vote yeah I've been trying to got
those for 10 years I've been trying to
develop it we're 55 of the population
the biggest swing voting block is women
there's an extraordinary that that like
every party with the exception of us
when we were a party
they all go for the woman's vote it's
like it's the only way it's like how
about the 45 yeah but if but if you you
know if they went for the 45 no but the
point is any individual party is very
unlikely to get that woman's vote
whereas if they thought well hang on a
minute there's a pool that's pretty big
over here nobody else is fishing in this
pool maybe you know well I think it's
because of the proper like women are
it's like you tell us some sad story of
a 13 year old girl getting raped and not
being able to get an abortion then we
run to the polls yeah they can't do that
to the men are so much more logical it's
so much harder to like win a guy over
yeah but women they can just like tell
us some story and we'll start crying and
run it yeah and then we'll filled I used
to campaign quite a bit on on that
Speaker's Corner
and sometimes I'd start to engage a man
is it interesting there's the difference
between men and women there
um I'd start to engage a man and and say
what I do and they'd be kind of like and
I said and in my early days I'd say are
you not interested in men's rights and
they turn around and say no and they
meant it they're not interested
um where whereas the women would vary
women one of the part of this
manipulation thing that always slays me
um is well obviously no woman has ever
lost an argument to a man it's just not
it's never been known but they always I
used to find and it was very funny if if
it was a woman with a partner a male
partner
because the guy would just be dying to
death thinking I want to be anywhere on
the planet rather than here because when
I'd show this woman that what she
believed was factually untrue they would
whip out the misogynist card
it's like it's like you know facts are
misogynistic it's like
and very often it occurred to me that
this isn't like debating with a
particularly stupid child this isn't
this is not adult Behavior
But but so many women do operate I think
on the level of children well
we're amazing
for 50 years well no that's a
that's a very interesting area because
how good of a person would you be if you
had to do nothing to be told you were
amazing all the time I know I know yeah
it's like and you know women can spend
their entire lives being told you know
through the media and so on but you go
back before mainstream you know
certainly before let's say television
and radio
um women didn't believe all this
[__] because they were surrounded by
by women who are who would they they
kind of didn't have this filter that
women are strong women are amazing women
need gender quotas no do you know what I
got into I had conservative and liberal
women arguing with me about this week
I said 25 year old women are better
looking than 35 year olds yeah yes I
erupted the internet
yes I'm like you know honestly
uh this isn't crazy yeah I could do 19
year old and 26 year I'm 26 I could say
19 year olds are better looking than me
I wouldn't be offended I'm like what is
wrong with these people like they're so
delusional that's crazy Andrew Tate of
course it appears Morgan when he
interviewed oh yeah there's a lovely
section he kept on trying to pin
misogyny on them you're old to the 26
year old right and I'm 26
that's misogynistic and they say
absolutely not he said he said the
perhaps sexist he said or something like
that he had a great line for it and then
they just I mean that guy is so smart
but uh that's something else
um no I know I'm a big Tate fan
um okay you said intimate partner
violence okay oh it actually first I
want to do employment that's after
education yeah I mean I I hear most
weeks from somebody
for men who um have been passed over for
promotion by by women
and very often these women are so in are
so inexperienced
that they will they I can't have a laugh
at this they will actually rely on the
men that they've been promoted over to
enable them to do their jobs
and you know we we have human remains
departments oh sorry Human Resources uh
departments um driving this and but it's
not just in promotion it's in
recruitment oh yeah we we had recently
um
stories about the RAF who stopped
recruiting white men
um and in fact a squadron leader was
like they they put in an email we don't
need any more useless white men joining
the RAF and I thought well you're quite
happier to have them in in in the Battle
of Britain yeah and without those white
men we'd all be speaking German and
life's tough enough without having to do
that yeah let me know how that goes we
put women in the military we'd be like
they'd be a disaster I mean but you know
there is not an area Pearl I know that
women
have not utterly corrupted and they're
they're doing it they they spent more
than five million pounds per nuclear
submarine in putting in women's quarters
and what do they find there's all these
Immaculate conceptions going on
um you know how do they get pregnant
it's just really weird you know a
thousand feet under the sea
um and then they fly them back from
whatever Port they're next in
absolutely insane I mean women
you know I think women should face the
military draft but not be on the front
line because they're a disaster I mean
men will prioritize
helping women over over winning gone
hear me out take away the right to vote
and ban them from the military it's so
cool yeah I don't really see that who's
gonna make the sandwiches
men probably do a better job they're
higher percentage of the
and have relationships like that's what
we're supposed to do have the nice
communities at home but now we just
pretend to be men you know not well not
well not well also have like repeal the
19th
um okay intimate partner violence okay
we sort of covered that with um yeah and
not being agenda this year but I'd just
like to touch on the issue of um
of money I mean it's the the
um in 1972 I think it was
um Aaron pitzy uh founded the first
women and children's refuge in Chiswick
in London and she was soon booted out by
radical feminists who realized that
there was a there was a huge potential
some you know funding available through
this and they have basically you know
corrupted I think in a given year
something like 500 million pounds worth
of money the government money
goes goes into the into the um into the
DV industry
almost nothing almost nothing for men
um and men men who are battered I mean
people often ask Men Who Remain with
abusive Partners why they do it and the
number one reason is to protect the
children
because they know if they leave the home
the children are going to be in the
front line
um and if um if a man goes to his local
Council and asks for accommodation
um because he's being beaten by his
partner
he'll be told that if he leaves the
house he'll be voluntarily homeless
so basically they go from living in this
house with this abusive woman to the
streets wow and that in itself is a
major I mean homeless people die on an
average 30 years younger than the
non-homeless and it's a major driver of
suicide I mean you know you hardly I
mean you hardly you see the occasional
female homeless person
but boy do they have to have lots of
problems to you know to get on the
street
there's a homeless shelter down the
street from here and I asked the one guy
that runs it like what causes it they
told me like single mother homes like
all these kids that were in and out of
foster care half their life yes yes yes
um yep which kind of goes back to like
why are we paying women to to leave and
have kids with multiple men I know it's
it's crazy
um
I used to know it's funny I used to have
zero sympathy for homeless people
because I felt like um
I just felt like like what why are you
unemployed like okay you know until
um I started doing the divorce
documentary all right and I realized how
many men are just like go absolutely
insane yeah and end up addicted to
things because
the wife has basically destroyed them
emotionally financially well the wife
has this date on the side and you can't
be the state yeah you know and they ruin
his reputation yes like I saw a video of
a guy that got killed because she
falsely accused him of being an abuser
yeah and these guys like saw oh it's
it's fairly common yeah it's the BBC
um
almost has almost never published a
piece about a man committing suicide as
a result of false false allegations but
they're fairly common and the one time
that they did was where the mother a a
year to the day after her son had
committed suicide did likewise and
because there was a woman involved there
then the BBC covered it
wow I read um a suicide note that was
from a guy in that situation in um it
was called the some it was Bob Lewis
book I read the other day I can't
remember what it was called but and it
was crazy to me that there was no
coverage on it because he basically said
it was because of the wife yeah that he
did it I think she's ruined my life
everyone thinks I'm an abuser
um took my kids took my money and now
I'm killing myself yeah and they don't
they don't cover it at all which is wild
to me well and you know the government
does not recognize suicide as a gendered
problem wow even when it funds to the
best my knowledge the government's never
funded research study
um specifically about male suicide and
the reasons for it uh well just who
cares about men I mean imagine Pearl if
the female suicide rate were three and a
half times a male suicide rate how many
billions of pounds would be pumped into
solving that problem well and the First
Response it's so crazy because we just
feminists have a way of just making
everything about us because when you say
that they're like well women attempt
suicide more wow yeah I mean anybody who
works for a for um suicide charity we'll
tell you in the heartbeat that most most
of those attempts are Christ for help
and I've I've only known two people
um trying to commit suicide
um but both are women and both took a
handful of paracetamol and they
immediately called for an ambulance
um
men soon learn that
um the the if they if you know they can
call for help but most of the time that
they won't get it and of course there's
victim blaming here so so so people will
say men to commit suicide they should
talk about their emotions more well I
say this you know if you're if you're
denied access to your children
and the emotional pain is such that you
would rather die how will talking to a
therapist well because they can't change
the reality and the thing is like
they're trying I always notice they try
to make men emote like women but women
don't like they're trying to make men
into women but women we feel the need to
talk about our problems all the time
just because that makes us feel better
that doesn't mean men will feel better
doing that no I agree if anything like I
mean I think you've ever like been in a
fight in a relationship like the women
want to talk about it the men don't yeah
like if it helped them why wouldn't they
want to talk about it
I think the number one thing that stops
men far more men killing themselves is
stoicism
yeah men get resilient so nobody ever
seems to say that I mean the idea that
men should be more like women oh give me
strength I mean that's just men should
be more like men yeah you know
old-fashioned men
um but I mean women should should women
need to get more resilient and nobody
ever says that do they so we get awful
bloody women like Laura I I can't have
it called Laura bloody Bates Laura Bates
who runs the everyday sexism project or
as we call it um the everyday whining
project
she wrote a book called um yeah we
always call it a special snowflake so
anybody who gets they know who specials
she wrote a book called
um men who hate women in which she
liable to me and a number of other men's
rights activists but she she's she's a
stunning example she's you know you
watch her for a bit and you realize what
you're watching
is a child in a woman's body
and so basically she wants a world
change so that women
um don't face any stresses and anxieties
and so on outside rather than say you
know what
um you know women should become more
resilient and she is she is absolutely
adored by young women and they become
totally dysfunctional special snowflakes
as a result and they lead miserable
lives
you mentioned paternity fraud in your
book yeah how common is paternity fraud
because the feminists just say it's
overblown it's not as common as we say
it depends how you define it actually
um I would include in it the number one
it's interesting um although it's it's a
crime under the fraud act
um the crown in the UK has never
prosecuted a single woman for it
um despite knowing I mean there's plenty
of women who go after a man for child
support and occasionally they have
enough brains to think hey maybe I'm not
that kid's
that kid's father and so then they have
to pay for a paternity test and when it
turns out that they're not the father
then it's dropped so the state knows
that flossie has lied about it but she
would she won't get prosecuted there's
even a thing called the slappers defense
and the slappers defense or sometimes
called the Halls Defense is that she
genuinely thought that this particular
man was okay and but it's always the
rich guy she knows it's never this is
um but no it's interesting um but
there's a form of what I regarded as
personality fraud
which is not actually a crime and that
is what Steve moxon
in his amazing Book 2008 book called The
Woman racket just a brilliant book
called upsing and that's where a woman
on oral contraceptives
um somehow becomes pregnant
because she's not been taking them right
um so as far as I'm concerned that's
paternity fraud that's a form
laughs
I have something to say
there's a victim right there
um so so so by some measures some people
estimate that more than 50 percent of
pregnancies
um and or kids are here because of 70
fraud but apparently yeah wow because
that is and you know you'll get like
Oprah Winfrey and so on saying laughing
about it and saying saying you know this
is this is how this is how to how to get
your man just just just forget to take
your pill
um but but you know there's there's
other forms I mean
uh
yeah it's it's it's
it's very debatable because of course we
don't have any any way of knowing how
common it is which is why one of the
things in our Manifesto was um and this
made the feminists go ape [__] so I know
I'm saying something right when they
when the feminist go ape [__] and this
was compulsory paternity testing at
Birth
oh it's like a paternity test at Birth
yeah and even if you're married never
mind you know yeah
um because that hardly protects you from
from paternity fraud does it
um yeah they they lost their [__] over
that why would they well because they
they because it's all about power so
they they would want women to cheat and
have have the steady guy with money you
know paying for it
wow how common do you think like what
percent of kids do you like it does like
what what percent of kids do you think
like as a dad raising a kid that's not
his
I would be surprised if it wasn't at
least 20 percent wow that'd be really
really astonished
you think paternity fraud
why do you think it's
oh well um again I'd refer people to to
our Manifesto where we have some
background
um there was a study conducted long
before DNA testing
um in a village in Sussex
and for whatever reason they they they
um they were checking out the blood
groups
of of adults and children
and I forget the figure now it's been a
few years since I looked at this but I
think in more than 20 more than 20 of
children were being brought up by by a
father who mistakenly thought
that that he was the father and they
knew that from the blood groups because
you know certain blood groups you know I
don't know how it all works but but yeah
so that was crazy yeah this is a village
for God this wasn't like some big city
or something this is a village so I mean
you know
so what about you you talk about how men
are discriminated against when it comes
to sexual abuse
yes
um
the
um something like in in straight
relationships something like a third of
uh sexual abuse Partners is is done
carried out by women
um the to the best of my knowledge
there's there's no British surveys in
this but the CDC you know the Centers
for Disease Control in the states have
for many years been um carrying out
surveys which which led to that
conclusion about a third of it is is is
carried out by by women on on on men
um people find that or very difficult to
believe
um but
um a third of sexual abuse is women on
men yeah in straight couples yeah
um it's called
um being forced to envelop or something
like force you know that and sometimes
with women
who who
um if it's a drunk man
a number of cases of that um you know in
a bid to get pregnant
um and so but the idea that it's
overwhelmingly a male on female thing is
again just one of countless countless
feminism but men will not go to the
police after after an incident like that
because they're they're they'd be a
laughing stock you'd imagine
um so so the prosecutions I mean I think
it's like 50 to one
um male female wow it's a you know
so how did they figure out that one out
of three all through through surveying
men and women yeah okay where they
didn't have anything to lose really just
by just by being honest
um so it says armed forces veterans
mental health issues ah yes um
um I mean this this touches to an extent
on homelessness I mean a lot of the
homeless are ex-armed forces
um and as you can imagine lots of
lots of veterans suffer from
things like anxiety disorders PTSD and
so on
um and a lot of them once they leave the
forces cope with that with drugs
primarily alcohol
but again I can only talk to the UK if
if if if if an ex-military person
ghosts ghosts
um you know once once
the health of a psychologist or a
therapist you know with that he will be
told he has to go six months without it
without alcohol
um beforehand well a lot of them kill
themselves in that time they can't they
can't manage six months they can't they
probably couldn't manage six days wow
and so that is a question I mean that is
just under investment as far as I'm
concerned in in mental health right but
I mean obviously Universe vice versa
well yeah but of course this is armed
forces so 90 of them plus are men it's
it's you know you think if men put their
lives at risk that the state would help
them afterwards but no they just wash
their hands of it wow
and then that also ties into prison
sentencing yeah yes I had a feminist on
Julie bindle's some State the other day
say that women
women were far more likely to be
imprisoned
than men is it's just are they
delusional yeah yeah
that's 95
yeah I went too low and and they're
closing women's prisons yeah they're
basically trying not to imprison any
women
um and and but they're building more
prisons for men so I guess it'll be 99
one but no the the again
um I might have mentioned this book
before but but he's extraordinary on
this but I mean men are several times
more likely Than a Woman
to be imprisoned for the same crimes
we're I mean once or twice a week I'll
do a piece I could do it 10 times a week
where a woman has committed a crime
where had she been a man
should have got several years
imprisonment but instead of which oh
Casey Anthony's one I don't know that
case she killed her her daughter she
like buried her in the backyard
like a newborn oh and
um yeah was this in the states or in the
states yeah she like got off I actually
don't even think she was convicted you
know it was super obvious like it was
her but it's always the same isn't it
yeah you know if a man kills a kid oh
they're monsters with women it's like oh
there must be a metal uh and uh and in
fact it's almost unknown for I mean
quite apart from women
slaughtering The Unborn in the tens of
millions
um it's almost unknown in the UK for a
woman to be prosecuted for killing an
infant under under 12 months
that's so crazy
yeah there is um I was on a show and
they asked me if a girl should face jail
time for taking abortion pills and
killing the kid at like seven or eight
months ah yes that was a famous case
recently yeah I know I was like yes
lock that [__] up
yeah they're like open for mental health
I'm like what the [__] oh cheers
we all have mental health issues like
get out of here yeah but the the
backstory was there was that she was
pregnant so she she was she had gone
back to her ex-hus saw her husband I'm
not sure which whilst pregnant with
another another man's kid oh [__] so it
was another man's kid yeah
um
and no it's absolutely premeditated
because feminists feminists just didn't
want because femish don't want any woman
to publisher Punisher or anything and
they want well I know in California
they're they're feminists are
campaigning for abortion up to birth
and in this country you can abort up to
birth for things like down syndrome and
cleft palate and it's it's scandalous so
disgusting that's so gross
but and they don't talk about what I
realized too they do with sexual abuse
they really call Everything's essay now
yes they've like expanded the definition
so much that I don't even know what it
means oh it's Madness no this this
definition dilution
um sexual violence now according to
feminists they'll put out you know every
time a feminist says one in three women
this one you always know it's a lie but
sexual violence willing this is this
kills even me sexual violence includes
being asked out on a date by a man you
don't want to be our star on a date by
so these are researchers that would
generally call that sexual violence I
didn't know I'm supposed to have been
traumatized I guess I'm sort of
traumatized
um
wow and then we talked about
that
the lack of a non Amendment anonymity
anonymity for suspected sexual offenders
yeah this is this is really egregious
and and a driver of male suicide I know
you you talked about that earlier
um basically any woman can destroy any
man just just in a heartbeat
um
she she will
um she will be remain anonymous for the
end of a to the end of her days but
protect you know her identity
but she you know a woman could say that
I'd raped her 30 years ago
um I'd have no protection I'd be in I'd
be in the Press
um
I hope I'm not giving feminist some some
suggestion there but if I I'd like to
anyway
um but they they destroy the men and
then and then they'll get you know a
whole bunch of other women say yeah he
raped me as well yeah it's so weird how
they all band together I'm like you just
have to know you're lying time and again
um I mean Tony danker the
director General and CBI was basically
fired recently you know but just
unsubstantiated allegations